[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Throughout
history, women have
enhanced their lips with color.
Cleopatra led the way
over 2,000 years ago.
She was crushed ants and
beetles to redden her lips.
Today a tube of lipstick
does the job nicely--
no need to mess around
with crushed bugs.
Lipstick comes in a case that
also serves as an applicator,
and that's the beauty of it.
Just twist the stick
and apply color to make
lackluster lips look luscious.
Lipstick ingredients
include waxes,
pigments, and moisturizers.
A worker pre-weighs everything
following a formula.
The exact blends are
usually a company secret.
She pours the measured
ingredients into a kettle that
melts and mixes them together.
She adds a plant-based
gel known as [INAUDIBLE]..
It will act as a skin softener,
and also enable the lipstick
to be smoothly applied.
Different waxes-- carnauba,
candelilla, and beeswax--
add body to the mixture.
The waxes will also give
the lipstick a certain sheen
upon application.
With the base mixture
prepared, she now
whips up a batch
of pigment using
different iron oxide colorants.
She scoops it onto
rollers that grind
the pigment particles while
rolling it into sheet form.
It takes three passes
through the rollers
to fully grind the pigment.
It's ready to be added
to the base mixture.
She lowers the heat
in the kettle to avoid
scalding the ingredients.
She adds pigment
until the mixture
thickens and becomes creamy.
It's now the right consistency
to be shaped into lipstick.
It's over to the
next station, where
another worker
pours the lipstick
liquid into a filling machine.
This filling system
also has a mixer that
keeps the consistency creamy.
She places a mold under
the filling machine
and activates a lift.
It serves up the mold to nozzles
that pump lipstick liquid
into the slots of the mold.
She continues to
fill lipstick molds
until the supply in the
machine has been depleted.
She places the
molds on a conveyor,
which takes them
through a nearly
5-foot-long cooling tunnel.
The chilly trip causes the
lipstick liquid to solidify.
The lipsticks are
now ready for their
swiveling tubular containers.
She places a rack
on top of the mold,
and inserts the cases
into slots in the rack.
The slots are aligned with
the lipsticks in the mold.
Then it's over to the
turnaround machine.
Bursts of air gently push
the lipstick out of the mold
and up into the cases.
To assist, little
pushers apply pressure
to the bottoms of the cases.
The lipsticks have made their
transfer without a smudge.
She sets them down and
removes the transfer rack.
On another conveyor, the
lipsticks pass by heat guns.
The hot air melts the
lipsticks just a little
to make them shine.
Continuing on, the
lipsticks travel
pass rollers that turn
the cases to cause
the lipsticks to swivel down.
A tester samples of
lipstick from every batch
to determine the melting point.
This is important,
because lipsticks
should be stable enough not to
melt in a purse on a hot day.
He smears lipstick
shavings onto a glass disk
and examines their consistency.
He places the sample
on a heating element
and swings a magnifying glass
overhead for a close-up view
as the lipstick shavings
melt into a puddle.
Checking the thermometer, he
confirms that the melting point
is within an acceptable range.
Another worker then
compares the color
of the freshly made lipstick to
the standard, and it's a match.
So they ramp up production
with a plastic cap.
The cap is clear to showcase
the shade of the lipstick.
It has taken about a day to
manufacture this lipstick.
It's time to freshen up.